مازلنا نترقب وننتظر القافله
المؤلفه من اربعه عشره شاحنه وهي من
منظمات خيريه ستدخل الاراضي السوريه
بالتعاون والتنسيق مع منظمتها التركيه
ولكن حتى اللحظه لم تصل كان قد سبقها
ظهر هذا اليوم دخول قافله امميه مكونه من
32 شاحنه تضم مواد اغاثيه وخيام ومعدات
لوجستيه اضافه طبيه وقد سبق هذه القافله
ايضا الوفد الاممي الذي دخل الى معبر باب
الهوى الحدودي
واجتمع خلال لقائه مع عدد من ممثلي القطاع
الصحي والعمل الانساني ليقف على
الاحتياجات ولكن بحسب ما اخبرنا الجانب
السوري هنا في اداره معبر باب الهوى انه
لم يرجع شيء عن الاجتماع سوى ان الاجتماع
كان بصيغه الاعتذار الاعتذار عن خيبه امل
السوريين
بالامم المتحده فجاء هذا الفريق ليعتذر من
الق على العمل الانساني وعلى القطاع الصحي
والطبي وايضا يعتذر من الخوذ البيضاء على
تاخير المساعدات سواء المعدات الثقيله
التي كانت ربما تساعد
فريق الخوذ بيضاء بشكل كبير في الايام
الاولى من عمليات البحث والانقاذ او حتى
في المساعدات الانسانيه التي تاخرت كثيرا
نحن نتحدث عن تاخير اول قافله مساعدات
امميه وصلت في اليوم الخامس من الزلزال
الذي ضرب منطقه شمال غرب سوريا اذا اردنا
ان نتحدث عن اجمالي المساعدات الامميه
التي قدمت منذ ان بدا الزلزال ضرب الزلزال
هذه المنطقه لنتحدث عن 85 شاحنه باكملها
بما فيها القافله التي دخلت اليوم اضافه
الى قرابه
58 شاحنه مقدما منظمات خيريه جاءت عبر
الحدود ولكن فدا اذا اردنا ان نوضح اكثر
حول الملابسات الحديث عن باب الهوى
الحدودي مع تركيا وادخال المساعدات من
معابر اخرى
حتى هذه اللحظه معبر باب الهوى الحدوديه
مع تركيا هو المعبر الوحيد التي تستطيع
الامم المتحده ادخال المساعدات منه بشكل
رسمي اما فيما تبقى من معابر اخرى كمعبر
راعي والحمام وباب السلامه وجرابلس ففقط
ربما تستطيع المنظمات الخيريه التي تعمل
بتركيا وبتنسيق مع الجانب التركي ادخال
هذه المساعدات من باقي المعابر ولكن ادخال
المساعدات الامميه من باقي المعابر يحتاج
الى قرار من مجلس الامن قرار جديد يتم فيه
تجديد التفويض لدخول المساعدات الامويه من
الامميه من معابر اخرى اذا اردنا نتحدث
ايضا عن الاحتياجات فالاحتياجات كبيره
بحسب القائمين على العمل الانساني هنا في
شمال سوريا نتحدث عن اكثر من 15 الف عائله
متضرره بفعل الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه
منطقه شمال غرب سوريا
نتحدث عن احتياجات كبيره من ناحيه الماوى
والصحه وهذه الامور ايضا بالنسبه
لاعداد الضحايا التي تصل تباعا من تركيا
الى الجانب السوري اليوم العدد وصل الى
1350 ضحيه تم استلامهم من قبل الجانب
السوري
وتم نقل جثامينهم
لتتفرق الى مثواه الاخير على طول المدن او
على انتشار المدن السوريه في شمال غرب
سوريا نعم